i think what we're seeing for the first
time in
american history since america has
become like a worldwide cultural
institution in
starting like the early 1900s to some
extent is you're having
creative types fleeing these
liberal you know uh currently democratic
areas like la new york
and everyone's moving to red states to
austin to miami and a few others
this has never happened before where the
creativity
goes to the republican party and i don't
see how
you reverse that trend
all right i'm dave rubin and we're doing
something a little different today i am
live in studio with my guest who is just
outside i have not seen him yet but i
have been told
that he is wearing a tiny mask
due to proper safety protocols related
to covid here he is michael
michael malus welcome to the ruby report
it's good to see you again yes feel like
face
this is very uh exciting i didn't know
what you were going to be doing today
um you told me you had something in
store for me it's good to see you
i wish i could say the same
but i can't honestly first off i love
the suit the color is great the shirt's
nice ty the the whole shebang where did
you get this
little face get up i know you've been
covet's very serious and you've been
very serious about it
you didn't even praise the shoes no your
shoes the whole thing is these are sea
leather
from the 70s is that right you could
when you could get seal leather that's
right
yeah that's very impressive nowadays no
no no you can't get it you have to get
on the black market now
um i have a feeling we're going to do
the entire interview this way
well of course this is we can't joke
around no no this is serious
yeah yeah i don't want to kill your
grandma no thank you they're both dead
well i don't want to kill her again
already yeah yeah
so you've been walking around like this
i assume wandering through la with with
your
i have a little cane and one of those um
uh dogs yeah and i fit right in
now are you here this is what i want to
ask you one of the things that i've seen
yes when i'm walking around l.a
uh i'm from new york as you know yeah
people you're a brooklyn guy i've lived
there all my life
and now i'm at the point where i'm
joined the chorus of well let me take a
step back
as a new yorker you're always defending
new york at its worst
right when people attack it for being
filthy for being crowd or for people
being rude
all my life i've said you just don't get
it
you don't understand or that's part of
what makes new yorkers tough
we can survive it you can't and only in
the last year
with kovid and what mayor de blasio
governor cuomo have done
have i come around to i was wrong
and these people were right what they've
done to new york city the crown jewel of
america
you know when the great cities of all
time is unforgivable and unacceptable
and there's no possibility in my opinion
of things getting better and i'm curious
you think they can never
in the medium term yeah in the medium
term there's no mechanism for it to get
better
if i'm a young person and i want to make
a store that sells like artisanal socks
cheeses i'm a young restaurateur i want
to open up a
cool new restaurant why would i go
into new york city now where every
single regulation is against me
where i'm being told constantly maybe
not explicitly but implicitly
we don't want you here you're not
welcome new york is not open for
business
and we're just going to shut you down at
the drop of a hat
and i feel as if la is
kind of similar in that vein that it's
going to get worse
because there's no mechanism for it to
get better i'm curious to hear your
thoughts on that
yeah well as you know i think la is an
absolute disaster and i've only been to
new york
once since i can't believe i'm talking
to you in this thing this is really
you look good you look this is actually
the best you've looked honestly of
course
you have to see my hideous face um
no i've only been to new york once since
this whole thing happened i was in
midtown manhattan because i was doing
the gut fell show at fox
and it was scary it felt like i am
legend there were there were no business
people out
there are only people out walking alone
with masks and hats
and it was kind of cold so jackets and
everyone looks kind of shady and there's
cops and a lot of barricades and all
that stuff and it's like
how does this ever come back and here i
mean you know the main the main not only
exactly where we are but the main drag
here still a ton of boarded up stuff
there's what what mom and pop shop
forget young people you said young
people what person that had their
business closed in the last year that is
experienced maybe even has a little
money could be like yeah let's do it
again
let's do it again so newsome can shut us
down next month and we have the climate
lockdowns or covid2 or
give me something better than that the
only possibility of things getting
better i tweeted this
this week if caitlyn jenner runs on a
campaign
of hitting and running governor newsom i
think she would get elected
in a landslide but here's what
what people don't appreciate they
thought one day
detroit could never go anywhere not only
was detroit motor city
the home of the automobile industry the
music coming out of detroit still
resonates decades later
still legendary decades later now
detroit is
a bombed out shelter of a hole in the
ground of what it used to be
hollywood in my view is running on fumes
on inertia
of the golden age you know you go to la
every pretty girl every
hunk from their hometown cup as you did
comes to los
angeles to make their name to make their
mark
and now the movie industry doesn't have
that cachet
it's not like the place you have to be
anymore because thanks to the internet
there's so many more venues for young
filmmakers
especially internationally to on a small
budget
create and innovate something amazing
parasite you know which came out of uh
south korea yeah
won the academy award there's such a
hunger
for and it's not even a right or left
wing thing there's such a hunger for new
voices
new creativity but hollywood and these
media establishment
entities are so corporate that whether
you're reading a comic book
or you're reading about the middle ages
or you're reading about a documentary
the messaging the culture the punch
lines are all
going to be the same so why would you
come here
where you could hang up your shingle and
be a filmmaker and be
as opposed to hollywood and you're going
to have some have an edge that way
we're going out to dinner after this are
you going to be dressed like this well
sure
how are you going to eat how you can eat
well i mean i want to cut i'm going to
be doing an underwear ad so
are you shocked so so look you live in
brooklyn i was born
in brooklyn and i've only lived in new
york and now l.a
you're a new yorker a true new yorker
are you shocked how quickly
everybody folded and that still now
people i assume in brooklyn are
wandering around with masks outdoors and
the
dingbats that i'm walking by over here
are you doing the same to tell you what
level of new yorker i am in the audience
yeah i don't know how to drive
so i'm going to have to learn how to
drive i am i'm
that's a true new yorker that's like
that's the true new york this is what
i'm shocked about
i am shocked to what level
americans who have prided themselves
on their sense of defiance who in 2016
had an opportunity to vote for someone
in large part to just give the finger to
the corporate press
how solidly they folded in the wake of
these lockdowns and were subservient it
and what's even worse and this is where
it gets from the point of
okay maybe you're a little bit weak
maybe a little bit fearful i can wrap my
head around that i'm not a particularly
tough guy
but when you see things like in canada
there was a woman who tweeted i'm sure
you saw this i'm sure many people saw
this
there was a i think was ontario where
the message went out that
your children should be quarantined
in a room in your home for two weeks and
when i went after this people
couldn't even believe it they assumed i
meant just being locked in your house
with your family which
isn't ideal but it's hardly a nightmare
right and the woman was tweeting that
it was heartbreaking for her to hear her
child yeah banging on the door saying
mommy i'm lonely or mommy
whatever it was i'm scared and i'm
thinking to myself i don't care what
your political persuasion is
if you or i or virtually anyone
listening to this if you're
like at a mall and there's a child who's
lost and scared
you if they're not ugly you stop and
you're like
what's wrong yeah how can i help you
let's find your mom and dad
let's keep you entertained and calm
until mom and dad get here this is just
humanity 101 and i say this as someone
without any facial features
so to have people not only do this but
to
post about on social media and not just
you would think that
i could even wrap my head around being
like oh yeah i'm totally doing this and
at home being like i don't care
what the news says exactly i'm not gonna
not hug my children exactly
so i'm an uncle now i've got two nephews
i absolutely adore them
and if someone says you know lock them
in a room for two weeks
we're not having a conversation that is
you declaring war in my family
so the twisted part beyond what the
mother's physically doing to the child
is the is the virtue signaling that she
then sends the message out oh it's
breaking my heart
what i've had to do as i've jailed my
child
what what kind of mental collapse do you
think we've really had as a society it
seems almost complete to me
i mean there are some sane people of
course there are some sane people
but like it seems like we have had just
like a cascading
collapse at almost every level at this
point i don't think it's a question of
sandy or insanity there's a there's a
quote i use all the time
from h.l menken if people don't know who
he is he was one of the great
controversialists
of the early 20th century he was a
newspaper man when newspapermen were
regarded correctly
as basically one step above a sex worker
or drug dealer just really
just the dregs of society and his quote
was
the average man does not want to be free
he simply
wants to be safe and i think a lot of
what you're seeing what you refer to as
the virtual signaling
things in social media the the exchange
the bargain is
i will do what you the people on the
screens corporate america the
politicians tell me
and in exchange you are going to tell me
that i don't have to worry about
anything
i don't think about anything i need
responsibility i'm just going to follow
orders
and be taken care of and what drove them
crazy to some extent about trump
is that they in a very literal sense
didn't know what to do
other than freak out they weren't being
given that kind of direct guidance
from the screens that they coveted so
much under
obama or even under george w bush i
tweeted this morning
a quote that you often put out there
which is that we didn't deserve trump or
we don't deserve we do not deserve him
yes
yeah do you miss him how much do you
miss him you know what's really sad
about president trump
is that he sends out these press
releases uh that are basically tweets
attacking people
you know many of the republican party
especially seem to be his targets
especially liz cheney
who i will remind everyone wants to kill
your children um i'm not even kidding
this woman
and her dad killed a lot of other people
absolutely
although you have to admit like you have
you really are kind of
like a baller if you shoot someone in
the face and they apologize to you like
that that
i gotta give uh dick cheney credit for
that um
google it if you don't know what he's
talking about yeah but uh i'm sorry i
lost my train thought what was the
question again
well trump like do you miss him right so
trump has been sending out these press
releases
and you're just imagining instead of him
having his blackberry whatever he uses
to send out these tweets he's standing
in front of a fax machine
you know age 70 whatever feeding these
press releases
and they're they're hilarious but it's
just not the same
right what i found uh really sick and i
think many people in the democratic
party as well i think 49 attorneys
general
have joined inside this lawsuit is the
facebook policy of
we're not going to allow president
trump's voice
to appear on this site now if it is your
belief
that president trump incited the worst
attack on american soil
since 9 11 and let's put things in
perspective
aoc had to see a cop for five minutes i
mean my god these people are still in
therapy because someone put up their
feet on nancy pelosi's desk dallas the
insurrectionist forgot to bring weapons
nobody had a gun and the only person who
got shot was one of them who happened to
formally be in the marines
in the most armed country uh or or
certainly uh one of the most
guns in the most armed countries in the
world so it's it's kind of
um just amazing how fragile
i think these elites have in a con
center control tower and how easily that
balloon
has been burst so how much of that and
the sort of hysteria now where nothing
makes sense and biden obviously has
dementia and the whole system is just
like
every even today literally an hour
before we're taping this i heard biden
is
going to build part of the wall it's
like everything is just an
epic amount of [ __ ] and it's
becoming
i think harder and harder for the
average person maybe they want to break
they either want to break everybody or
they want everyone to give up maybe
that's the same thing
or or they want everyone to know not you
know which way is up and
what do you think i mean is it is it a
systemic systemic
are they systemically just trying to
break our spirit is that really what's
happening well i think a large part of
what's kind of the message is that their
memory lasts like six months
it's really kind of bizarre i'm sure you
and i and many other people are not
alone
in the fact that jimmy kimmel has like
george w
bush on where like a few years ago
they'd be talking he's a war criminal
this guy's literally the worst president
i mean and now you know he's just their
pal
the same people who think president
trump was hitler
right and this is are regarding liz
cheney the imperialist warmonger
as a responsible sane person there's
there's this bizarre
uh um detachment from reality but that's
a good measure
of knowing if your process is working if
it's much easier to train a smart dog
than a dumb dog so if you
see all these educated not unintelligent
people
targeting the same message you know that
your process of programming them
has been working and this has been going
on for over 100 years you had books by
walter lipman
bernays is another one and the the
question was
uh and this speaks to like the early
days of mass media
how do we the elites who have an earned
right to rule
and to create order out of chaos through
our regulation
and control how do we manufacture
consent and noam chomsky who's a fellow
anarchist of mine
had a book on this subject and his
reaction was
the best way to do this is to have
strictly
limited area of debate but strong
disagreement within that area so
whereas you and i or somebody else might
say let's have the debate range between
one and ten
they'll have it between six and seven
well there's infinite numbers between
six and seven six and a half six point
seven
and have everyone argue and think you
can't get outside this very strictly
limited thing and you see
all the time how the language for
heretic changes it's racist it's
insurrectionist it's white supremacist
uh it's it's q anon more people on the
left
talk about q anon than i've ever seen in
social media
coming from the right i've told this a
couple times on the show but i went to a
trump rally in beverly hills i went to a
few of them
and at one rally there was one woman who
was into queue that came up you know
everyone knows me there they all come up
to me
everyone says nice things this woman
come up to me she goes dave what do you
think about cue ball and i was like
honestly i've never talked about it on
the show i haven't paid any attention to
it i don't know anything
and she got very pissed at me because
she was a cue person she grabbed a
bullhorn and started screaming that dave
rubin's hearing he doesn't believe in
cue
and everyone walked away from her and
everybody was like dave what do you
think of that crazy woman
and it's like that's what cnn needs they
need that crazy woman
yeah and it's i i uh justin amash who's
a former congressman i'm
sure you've probably talked to him at
some point he had me speak to a class
that he was teaching or lecturing at
the university of chicago and the first
thing i said to him is
my goal today is to make you regret this
and i was talking about public education
uh when the students went on twitter and
the point being that the purpose of
public education isn't to educate
children it's in their own words to
create better citizens
what that means is to break young
spirits and make them subservient
and obedient and the girl immediately
said how can you be talking about this
conspiracy
this word is used i never said
conspiracy this is something
is there a conspiracy among pro-life
people to eliminate abortions
is there a conspiracy among businesses
to get tax cuts and regulatory cuts
that further industry or to increase
regulation to keep competition out but
they just throw out this word
to mean any kind of organization that's
deleterious to their interests
and it's a mechanism to forestall any
kind of future debate and discussion
and i gotta say i'm very very hopeful
for the future of this country
because there is an increasing amount of
recognition
on all sides of the political spectrum
that political
discourse and discussion are becoming
close to impossible
no one believes each other no one trusts
each other's motives
and in my view with very very very good
reason
okay bye you're giving me a lot malison
i can't even see your beautiful face
i don't have one you're just the
faceless
political operative now i'm an npc yeah
you're a complete mvc that you could
have been you could have dressed up as
the npc which is
full-on grade i i'm too much of a blue
check to ever be an npc a little inside
baseball lingo
i got it i got it um let's just back up
though because to the mask thing for a
second because i'm still seeing people
wearing masks
right here and it it seems to me that
they've triggered this fear thing in
people that they're gonna always do this
they're gonna always do this where years
ago you'd go to the airport and you'd
see
asian people wearing masks and you were
like oh are they sick or are they
protecting us from being sick or what's
going on here
like they'll they've now just trained us
to do all these things and we've broken
down the basic
social fabric you go to a store you
barely you know you're wearing a mask
they're wearing a mask you barely look
at the cashier
in the eye we don't go to movie theaters
anymore that we've broke
down all of the stuff you don't go to a
bar and sit at a i used to love
just sitting at a bar and getting a
drink and talking to somebody or talking
to the bartender they've broken all of
that
and that's going to have all sorts of
repercussions that we probably can't
even imagine at this point uh my buddy
tom woods uh
yeah i did a cartoon retreat with you in
a second
like he made the point he's a dad he's
got i think uh five daughters
he made the point what about like
three-year-old children or four-year-old
children what about dogs
like to live in a society where you
can't see people smiling at you
this is something that has profound and
severe long-term psychological
consequences
you know a lot of times people who are
holier than now smarter than everybody
else you know
urban elites make fun of religious
people but you're when you're four or
five years old
you're basically training to think that
they're these invisible demons
everywhere they go on sigh
outside and without this magical piece
of fabric in front of your face
you're one day away from killing your
grandparents this is
not a healthy psychological message to
tell children that you should be afraid
of leaving the house what about how
they've butchered science i mean there's
almost nothing even even me
i mean i'm fairly well read i talked to
some interesting people yeah
i'm pretty much completely skeptical of
anyone that says anything about science
you say the word science and i'm like
what are you talking about i mean
that fouchy in effect has destroyed the
complete ability for anyone to believe
anything at least in my opinion i mean
it's even broader than that because
we're being told every five years we
have 10 years to save the planet
and the only way to save it is to
basically destroy all industry
and even if that happens we're still not
going to save it anyway but we should
still do it
for some you know dubious purpose so the
goalposts keep changing
and i think i've mentioned this
previously on the show i know i've
spoken of it before
this goes back to the early days of
progressivism and woodrow wilson
uh because one of the things that
happened during the great war
was this was the big if i can pardon my
french progressive wet dream
which is we're going to have washington
as this super state
governing every single aspect of our
country
of our economy of our culture now they
had an excuse it was the great war this
is you know world war everyone's
involved
but this was a great dress rehearsal
for the great depression the new deal
because they can say look
15 years ago you guys all did this you
guys handed over all your authority to
the state to washington
this is a bigger crisis than the great
war and that's actually true
like in terms of which is a bigger
threat to america the great depression
or the hun it was certainly the great
depression
and you know i tweeted this out i think
a year ago some
ver like it or not wrongly or rightly
whatever the science is
some very very bad people have a lot of
very useful information
about how much people will put up uh
with these lockdowns and
they could use that information in the
future and they're not going to use it
for nice things
right so what do you think comes after
this you've had a pretty good track
record on
projecting all of this and i think you
have a good sense of the
one a general yeah one of the things i
am
i'm very optimistic about the future as
i said earlier in the show and in
general
and i when i'm optimistic i think
optimism has to be based on data
it's not just like everything's going to
be fine that is not the case there's
many cases where things
are not fine or they're only fine after
a very long period of time one of the
things
i am shocked and delighted by is how
many people on the right especially
conservatives
have seen the cops for what they are as
you know i'm an anarchist i have could
not have a worse opinion of the police
but they are understanding that the
police are not
their friends the police will follow any
law
that is being passed and when these
conservatives start defending the police
i ask them
how much money would it take you or
would it take for gretchen whitmer
to force you to lock an old person in
their home how much money would it take
for andrew cuomo to tell you to keep
someone away from their dying mother in
a hospital
so there it's a question of conscience
if you're going to just follow orders
if you're going to wave the basic
element of what separates us from the
lower animals
this sense of right and wrong and we see
it in
city after city after city the police
stand down
and the only people who are punished are
those who have guns
or those who are trying to defend
themselves or their communities in fact
we saw i believe it was in portland
uh when the attorney general barr sent
federal troops to guard the courthouse
he was the one who was hauled before
congress
of having to explain himself how dare
you send in troops to defend federal
property from being destroyed
it's a complete ask upside down world so
how much damage has to happen to these
cities before
something turns around either through
the people or through
better governance i suppose i know
that's not really your thing but like
does portland have to just completely
become ground zero does seattle have to
collapse does new york city does
la san francisco like what like what
actually do you think has to happen at
the human level that gets people
going okay we gotta turn this around or
does everyone just have to flee the
cities
i think what we're seeing for the first
time in american history
since america has become like a
worldwide cultural institution
in starting like the early 1900s to some
extent is you're having
creative types fleeing these
liberal you know uh currently democratic
areas like la new york
and everyone's moving to red states to
austin to miami and a few others
this has never happened before where the
creativity
goes to the republican party and i don't
see how
you reverse that trend let's is the
question is going to be
you know how did la get destroyed to
quote
hemingway two ways gradually and then
suddenly yeah
i don't see a mechanism or even a desire
because when people complain in these
cities
about how how hard it is cuomo is a
great example of this
there was a press conference during this
whole covet thing and he was asked like
you know how do you you know you're
destroying these small businesses and
very flippantly
he was like well if i have to choose
between a lot of people dying and a lot
of businesses going out of business
it's not an easy choice but it's also in
one sense not a hard choice
so there's not even like a sense of
handwringing
what have we done what has the cost been
because it's very useful
for the corporate media to not speak
about trade-offs thomas soule who i
adore and you're obviously a huge fan
uh says talks about instead of thinking
about like good or bad
at what costs and compared to what to
talk about costs and benefits
but they don't want to think about costs
and benefits they don't want to think
okay this is a good thing
but it's expensive or this will help
this group but it's hurting these 10
other groups it's more like
it's the right thing to do don't ask any
questions and like if something is the
right thing to do
in this short term that's certainly a
possibility what are going to be
the long term costs and how do we fix it
they were tripping over themselves in
2008
to bail out the banks and now every
little business that i loved in new york
stores have been around since the 70s
the 50s they're boarded up the signs are
still there because they were proud this
is a family institution
they're gone and they're never coming
back and no one
cares do we have to jail some of these
people i mean is that like the end that
basically cuomo and whitmer and newsome
that
it's very obvious there was no science
behind the lockdowns they decided to
destroy millions of lives
i think that killed literally kill the
elderly in cuomo's case and probably in
whitmer's case well no not probably
let's talk about that video i'm so
interrupted but that video went viral
there was this kid
i i think he was 17 18 19 was in a
nursing home
and was beating up elderly people in
their beds
and posting it on social media this went
viral oh was that a michigan i know
he was in those homes because by law
it was mandated they're going to be
quarantining them in these
locations she so it's not maybe she was
killing person after person and i have a
uh
i'm sure you saw this on twitter if you
go to governors to gitmo.com
i've got the t-shirts to that's my
answer to this problem right so but
really
just one more thing i'm sorry it's not
going to change
until politicians have consequences on a
personal level
for their malfeasance and depravity i
don't know what that looks like
but it's certainly more than them
getting voted out of office this cannot
continue and i think they are pushing
america
in a very dangerous direction
brinksmanship is something that
very rarely has a happy ending well it's
like every day now
in california newsom's coming out and
we're giving you stuff
more money for you guys and it's like
wait a minute how do progressives
suddenly think giving us money is good i
thought that taxes are bad but it's all
the tax money you took from us in the
first place i mean
i know none of it really makes any sense
but okay if voting amount's not enough i
mean really what what do you think
either the jailing or like
what are we gonna send them to the
phantom zone like what are we gonna do
with these people
i'm okay with the phantom so but but
really like what's the real
thing because these people deserve none
of our respect or attention or money or
power or anything
i think something that's very you just
hit the nail on the head
one of the things that president trump
did very very well and there's a lot of
things he didn't do so well
is he demonstrated that these people
should not be treated with respect but
be treated with open
brazen contempt if you are telling me
that i cannot hug my child if you are
telling me
that i can't see my mother breathe her
last breath
in this hospital this is not like well
i've got one opinion you've got another
opinion let's just kind of hash it out
and agree disagree
this is completely in my view beyond the
pale
and the time for conversation has ended
there there's and the thing is
the republicans need to go on offense
instead of constantly having to
apologize and discuss
the hard left's idea du jour here's one
example
everyone now in this country who's
politically minded
has an opinion on whether we should
defund the cops right
everyone talked about everyone most
people are against it but everyone
discussed it
why is no one discussing ending
birthright citizenship
uh my personal idea is to have a using
the second amendment
and using the logic of obamacare make
gun ownership
mandatory the second amendment says a
well-regulated militia which means
a militia of citizens who are regulated
who are informed and practiced
in the use of their firearms is
necessary for free people
so either you get a gun or you can't
vote things like this
now the new york times is going to freak
out the washington post is going to
freak out
don lemon is going to you know have a
meltdown on air
that's going to happen regardless yeah
ann coulter had this great quote where
she says
attention republicans if the new york
times isn't calling you racist
you're losing so the record for the
record huh called me a white supremacist
this week pretty good
really yeah well they asked andrew yang
why he goes on white supremacist shows
in effect
me they called it the dave rubin show
this is the reuben report i couldn't
even get them to retract that i didn't
even care about the white supremacy part
i was like ah
you know we've done that a million times
already but they got the name of the
show wrong they wouldn't even fix that
but you know what else is amazing so
it's an honor it's also it's also
amazing that you would ask a politician
why would you want to promote your views
on a place that has an audience
isn't it it's really funny because on
the one hand you have the maxine waters
types and
i do like her antagonism and aggression
i'm not gonna lie but she's saying if
you see someone from the trump
administration at the gasoline station
at the mall you go up to them and you
say you're not welcome here
i would you would expect them to if you
are a white supremacist if you're a
homophobe if you're an anti-semite all
these things which we know you are
right to come here and be like screw you
dave reuben
you're terrible your ideas are horrible
you're this you're
that and so on and so forth that you
want to take the fight to the enemy
malice this is why i love you malice
it's a great point
i don't know yeah it's somewhere over
here i think yeah it's over there
uh it's a great point on one hand
they're saying get in their faces
don't let them have an inch blah blah
and then on the other hand they're
saying don't talk to them at all and
pretend they don't exist
and we saw a great example of this when
brian stelter
from cnn he had a panel and they were
freaking out
that venues like tim poole like your
show
joe rogan several others have bigger
audiences of cnn
and people are getting the wrong
information by which they mean
information they don't like and what are
we going to do about this so their
agenda is basically well let's pretend
that dave's reuben don't exist the tim's
pool don't exist
well that became too hard your audience
is too big your social media following
is too big
now it's like well an individual level
maybe we'll start him out of guests
you have no shortage of people idiots
from brooklyn you know dressing like
question
banging down your door to try to get on
this show so that's not really going to
work
but it shows their desperation the fact
they're running out of ideas
so then what's after that because i've
been saying for a while i mean all of us
have a limited window on social media
i'm thrilled that i think you were the
second guy on local
basically and and you're killing it on
there but it seems to me that because of
exactly what you just said there that
the jig is up they've been exposed
everyone gets it they can't let us on
youtube and twitter and facebook much
longer like it just
can't it's not tenable but i've always
said there's going to have to be
alternative
sources into for people and their all
culture has to diffricate
in order to go forward back in the day
it was abc nbc cbs
now in terms of news there's literally
thousands of sources some of them are
completely wrong and misinformation and
kooky
some of them it's a spectrum some are
you know objective and spot on the money
they are the only way the new york times
can be the
new york times in terms of stature is if
it has close to monopoly on the
microphone
and i don't see how like humpty dumpty
once that egg is shattered
how you put it back together again you
were never going to be again as a
country
and it's not even in terms of the news
look at like the mash finale
for kids there was a show called nash
yeah which is about the korean war
what was the number what was the number
on the finale 60 million
yeah but even the super bowl yeah this
was something that everyone air quotes
in america is watching
you can't get that together in terms of
the new york times or even cbs abc nbc
and
nbc news anymore our country has become
too split up
and that's choice is the basis of
liberalism
that's what liberalism means you have as
many options and you're free to choose
as you wish but this is a big threat
because their entire worldview is based
on their depravity and malfeasance
they're more upset that someone had
their feet up on nancy pelosi's desk
that many people in the elites were
possibly engaging in statutory rape
with jeffrey epstein and abc news knew
about this and didn't inform the
authorities
but the guy had his feet up he was
wearing his shoes he took a picture i
mean
were they still leather they were not as
fancy as your shoes that's for sure
so at what point do you think we've
crossed the rubicon here have we crossed
the valley let's say where we should
just start ignoring them i i struggle
with this all the time
because okay go ahead the battle is one
when the average american regards a
corporate journalist exactly as they
regard a tobacco executive
now whenever i say this some midwit has
to get on twitter and say the tobacco
executive's much better
yeah i said regards and that is the next
step
you have to realize i'm not catholic
you're not catholic
uh i like the pope some of the popes i
like some i don't like
you can hear him out but there's no
reason for me
to believe everything he says or to
trust him to some exceptional degree
so the thing is there's no reason the
same way to believe
cnn fox nbc these are corporate entities
with an agenda and if you're at a point
where coca-cola
is telling their employees to be less
racist it's
given coca-cola's extremely racist
history right they
sort of backed off this thing though
right they didn't they delete some of
the
diversity and inclusion and that's the
point like now they are
trying their shenanigans but people are
on to them and instead of trying to have
this
lively debate it's like we're not having
this conversation this is just a
mechanism for you to further your power
and we're going to have to fight back
because i am not going to bend the knee
to your nonsense any longer
especially because constantly and
explicitly
you're coming for our children do you
think it's possible that they've awoken
a real lion here like a real beast and i
mean that in the best sense that i
i just tweeted this out in the last
couple hours something about like we
need
rallies again like the trump rallies
were so much joy so much positivity
so much true diversity and all of that
stuff and i'm not saying it has to be
trump doing it i personally wouldn't
have a problem if it was trump
but like do we just need like they in
effect they've awoken something that we
must get out there and show them that
we're here that that's the only way and
they locked us in our houses
to make sure we couldn't do it do you
know why while they bowed at protesters
those rallies are
great here for the simple reason that
it's a symbol of
defiance yeah everyone remembers how
governor abbott of texas he rescinded
some of these mandates
governor newsom of california tweeted
out that it was unacceptable or i don't
remember what term he is but he was
basically condemning it
nothing happened as a consequence and
everyone pretended it didn't happen
so if you have these big rallies which
they're going to be described as white
supremacist rallies they're going to
describe it that way anyway
uh and this is showing people we're not
going to
stand six feet apart from each other and
no one's going to die as a consequence
we're going to be safe and so on and so
forth
that kind of element of defiance is
useful
because people in the middle is
something called the bandwagon effect
people in the middle are who don't
really have a political opinion one way
or another
but basically you know all my life i'm a
new yorker i'm not a sports fan
people like yankees or mets i would say
mets because i like the blue and the
orange better i
literally have no other mechanism for
choosing but if you have no mechanism
for choosing
you're going to go to the people who are
having fun yeah you're going to go the
people who have the energy
so if you have one group that's like be
miserable never go to a concert
the other one's like don't you want to
have like rock and roll and listen to
even elvis
it's like yeah i'm gonna go to where the
people are having fun are and that's a
big threat to their control
so in many ways this is what you would
have wanted to happen a long time ago at
some level right that
that the right the new right to use the
title of your book that the new right
would become the place that was creative
and cool and there would be music and
parties and fun and
sex and all of those things that humans
are supposed to do and all the left has
is preening fake morality and hysteria
and lunacy well i don't i i mean i'm
going to be a little bit pedantic i
apologize i wouldn't call it fake
morality
they really have a very strict
puritanical morality
which is fake meaning it's not moral in
a
objective sense no it is moral and
objective sense in the sense that like
it
a morality let's get my yaron brook hat
on okay
uh morality in the iran sense is
basically a code of ethics
or code of values which governs every
aspect of your life
keeping kosher in the jewish ethics is a
good example of acting
ethically every choice you make with
your food is
guided by this ethical code they have
and they've extended that
to literally every aspect of your life
who you sleep with
uh what kind of food you eat it's gotta
you know be ethical local so on and so
forth
how you dress what shows you watch who
you
interview on your own set and
it it's it's just amazing to what extent
this is the other thing i point out
if you're talking and talk discussed
about this in my book if you're talking
about video games
sci-fi fantasy comic books places where
people go to escape reality
and escape the earth and have this kind
of sense of adventure
their morality and their worldview even
permeates their
there's nowhere on earth space time or
the future where you can go to escape
their edicts
and at a certain point many people are
like i don't
want to live like this i want to judge
my friends
on are they going to be there for me
when i have a tragedy
or not who they voted for or whether
they think trump is hitler as opposed to
maybe they think he's just a buffoon
how much further will they crack down
then right they're not going to just
give up like okay so we start
rallies again we're creating good stuff
we're doing all the stuff that you would
like
to see happen and by the way i do think
it's happening right oh yes it is
happening there's no doubt about it but
yes
they're not just going to give up
they're not just going to walk away and
and even when coke reverses slightly
it's
diversity stuff it's like well what are
you really saying yesterday you were
telling
half your employees that they're racist
now you got exposed so they're not like
i remember last year what do we do with
this i i meant i said
the the riots are about 72 hours away
from having corporate sponsorship
and it was like like two hours later
everyone's bending over backwards
to endorse these uh um the civil unrest
playstation i literally turned on my
playstation and it offered me a free
black lives matter
background it's on there yeah right but
it's it's amazing to what it's right so
everything has to be permeated with this
very speci and it's not only like
it it'll be one thing if they had said
we want people to
value black lives more it specifically
just has to be this one slogan and we're
this month we're only caring about black
people next month we're caring about
this group next month occurring about
this group and if you're a poor white
person and you're resentful
well you had your turn you know go home
and suck it up
so i i don't think this is something
that's going to be able to last much
longer
and i have to give credit to people on
the left people like james carville
van jones and some others where they're
like this is something that
cannot long-term sustain itself and
britain
of all places i mean talk about just uh
terms
of backward [ __ ] they just had their
local elections after having a new
leader for labor
which is one of their two main parties
cirque here and he was much more
uh to the center than their previous
leader jeremy corbyn they had their
off-year elections
and they were seeing their biggest
losses since like world war ii
so if you're and you're seeing this also
in germany uh the social democrats which
are
historically the second biggest part in
germany are now calling it like 11 or 12
percent
so in country after country this old
coalition
of the left being the party of the labor
unions the working man
they now have such contempt for the
working man especially in america since
reagan
when you had union workers who were
voting republican
they just threw themselves they got
thrown to the garbage as quickly as
possible
and this is what i think people on the
right don't understand they
don't care about muslim immigrants
mexican people at the border
transgender rights it's whatever group
is of use
at the moment to further their agenda
and once that group is not
behaving or acting in the way that they
like they're just swiftly discarded
here's a great example that's not even
an identity politics group
everyone can look up and probably
remembers
they had these stopping bullying
campaigns all the nerves getting shoved
into lockers we need to put a stop to
this this is terrible
this is not who you are as a country
true then came gamergate
and the nerds were the first ones to
fight back nerds fought back
do you think it's all really connected
to that yeah the nerds fought back they
were like we're not
we just want to play video games we
don't care about identity politics in
star wars
and all the narrative now became that
those people who play video games are
not only racist but are potential school
shooters
two years ago let's not bully them now
they're an existential threat to this
country in the world
did it all start there yeah with the
gamergate thing that was the first time
where you had a group that just wanted
to mind their own business
and they realized and the entire machine
yeah they will not leave us
alone we just want to sit at home
in our underwear eating our cheetos with
our headphones and our war station
playing this dopey game and even in my
basement where i have no friends
i still can't escape you and your
clutches
whew malice malice we got we got a lot
of stuff to fix let's jump back for just
a second because you said something
about the democrats not being or
in effect the left not being the party
of the working man but but
they want 15 minimum wage wouldn't that
be the greatest thing for the working
man that doesn't that mean they
care about the working man malice i'm
smiling as i say this to you
in terms of the minimum wage i am one of
the few people who are anarchists who
are in favor of raising minimum wage
because i cannot handle dealing with
cashiers
all their job is is to input mistakes
between me
and the touch screen um and listen if
the minimum wage in effect
gives people more money it and doesn't
hurt jobs i'm all for it
but it really but you know that's not
true right and the minimum wage is zero
and it's always going to be zero no one
ever expected that a minimum wage
one of the things you see these tropes
on social media is that a minimum wage
job
can't pay for a one-bedroom apartment
yeah it's called minimum
yeah a minimum wage job should pay for
the minimum
size apartment that's just the logic to
it and minimum wage jobs have never been
designed for someone to provide for a
family it's for people who are marginal
it's people who are teenagers
people who are maybe getting out of
prison or something trying to get their
feet on the ground people who used to be
homeless or unemployed or people who
really just are struggling
and they're trying to make their way
through night school or building up the
resources in other catastrophes in terms
of their career
or their resume so but can you give me
the true anarchist version of just
why the government has no right to tell
you how much you have to pay
somebody give me like your pure
anarchist 101 version you just did it
oh i know i don't know but i was trying
to be a good host and let you do it
all government edicts have no authority
whatsoever
just because a bunch of people in
philadelphia had a conspiracy
and signed a piece of paper the fact
that that is going to have to have an
impact between my relationship with you
in terms of how much money i'm offering
you for your services
or your book or your choose or anything
like that
there's absolutely no role for the state
to get involved in a situation like that
and it's the poor people who are always
the first ones to be hurt and
this is why corporate america loves it
yes i'm walmart on target i can afford
to pay my workers at the very bottom
more but that little store
where that one extra employee is the
difference between having two people
mom and dad and three that's a 50
increase in terms of my productivity
i'm the one who's going to be screwed
sort of like how the lockdowns allowed
for target to remain open but the little
mom and pop store that sells the same
stuff as target next door wasn't allowed
to remain open
by the orders of the democrats we have
seen a systemic assault
on middle-class businesses by corporate
america both
in terms of them cheering on the literal
physical destruction
in terms of looting and rioting and
saying it's mostly peaceful
meanwhile kovid remember they were
saying was like seven like 93 percent of
these protests were peaceful
well kovit has a 99 survival rate and we
had to shut down the earth
so that you laugh but the science math
come on they
they say whatever is of use to them in
that moment to further
power and they will never apologize for
being called out on their crop here's
another good example
that's that is transcends partisan poli
political lines we were told in 2020
early 2020
that there's about to be a genocide of
the kurds in syria
and that if we don't have american
troops there tomorrow
boots on the ground this is going to be
another holocaust
we did not have boots on the ground the
kurds have not been exterminated as a
race
trump got us out and no one who was
arguing for
killing american soldiers had any
shame or consequences for what they had
been
advocating speaking of no shame and
consequences i think you went
after him on twitter so i will bring it
up because i had to do it too even
though he's been on my show
but uh david frum in the last couple
days with everything
going on in israel and he starts going
off on trump look at those trump peace
deals that didn't accomplish anything
this is the man
who literally wrote the axis of evil
speech that lied us into the iraq war
part of all of it is that they have no
shame right like like what do you think
that is psychologically actually
is that is it just self-preservation it
is a very sad thing
to be closer to your coffin than to your
prime as a man
and it is a sad testament to the history
of this country
how we treated women how we treated
minorities how we treated gay people
that all the appropriate words to
describe david from
have misogynist or homophobic contracts
you're good malice you're good let's
back up to something you said earlier
you mentioned van jones and who was the
other one uh james carville
as sort of the democrats or lefties who
were kind of trying to do something from
the inside
you know a little bit of the history of
dave rubin i tried it as a lefty
i wrote a book defending liberalism and
how it's different than leftism
i'm the why i left the left guy you
think they have any chance like what do
you make of those people
trying to do that thing at this point
let me say something that's going to
make some conservatives very upset
corporate democrats have been a lot
better and stronger at defeating the
hard left in 2020 than the republicans
were
joe biden's nomination was the
democratic party getting on the phone
with amy kloechar
with karma harris with pete buda judge
saying bonnie's the nominee
you're folding your campaign today
you're getting on a plane today
you're endorsing biden and he got the
nomination
where can i pause your phone so just to
be clear so they all did that the day
before super tuesday so that
that the next day in effect that tuesday
biden would basically get the nominee
although he has turned out to be far
worse you would agree right
then then what like how much worse could
this be if bernie was in charge right
now
i think you could argue it's actually
worse because every because it came in
cloaked
as opposed to being obvious what it was
that that's a very interesting
conversation to have and
you could easily in my view maybe during
an interview no but i'm saying i can
easily argue for both sides it's a very
nuanced
do you want someone who is honest and
an ideologue or is it easier to get over
if you're kind of passing as being in
the middle how much of this is binds
ideas how much of it is the ideas of
people behind him
i find it hilarious that the leaders of
black lives matter
publicly said biden and kamala harris
won't even take our calls
yeah they haven't even been inaugurated
yet it was just an amazing thing
uh to watch so this is but the thing is
i think people on the right
tend to uh regard the democratic party
in the left as a monolith
it's the same people who would tell you
that i mean if someone told you that jeb
bush
is the same thing as trump is the same
thing as hitler you're on the right
you're all republicans
it's just nonsensical and van jones as
you mentioned is a good example
he's a former communist literal
communist but the commies
really often have this red pill
perspective because they understand how
corporate politics work
they understand the inner relationship
between corporate america
and the political process and how the
little guys always want to get screwed
so where do you think guys like them end
up at this point
what do you mean where does a guy like
van joe like the guys that are still on
the left that are trying to negotiate
with the woke thing trying to make sense
abide in like
you know the few that are still somewhat
sane in the midst of this where where do
you think they sort of end
do they end up where i'm at there's a
few let me ask you a question a second
there's a few scenarios one is they win
and they basically
purge the party or marginalize these
loons
and and have them just be in the garbage
can or
okay let's say that's not going to
happen or they're driven out of the
party or they're the ones who are
marginalized but this has been going on
since
uh the 90s at least the clintons with
the dlc the democratic
leadership council was called or what it
was called the idea was we're going to
be the new
moderate democrats he did balance the
budget against his will
uh he did limit spending against his
will passed again
ban on gay marriage which is a
conservative idea so
bill clinton in many ways is better at
delivering ostensibly conservative ideas
than many of the republicans ever were
so i think politics is often
counter-intuitive in terms of who's the
vehicle who's going to deliver the goods
that you want
richard nixon brought about a laundry
list of leftist
uh list streams including wage and price
controls which even bernie sanders isn't
advocating for
right what about the we talked a little
bit about
let me ask you that question you tell me
what is the process
when you start out as james carville who
i'm sure would have been somewhat close
to your worldview
at the time he's a savvy democrat he's a
practitioner he's a strategist but now
you know you voted for trump what were
the steps
if you sat down with dave rubin or dave
rubin
at that time to get you from there to
voting for someone who you might have
perceived as hitler
well i think the final step i'll give
you the final step first the final step
for me of being okay with trump
is that i actually met the guy at
mar-a-lago and that when he was
introduced to david and i
and realized that david was my husband
and he said gay gay
and he slapped the table and stood up
with this huge smile
and shook our hands and thanked us for
being there and then turned to melania
and said you know can you believe it
these guys are gay their only problem is
they're they're too handsome
it wasn't that he was complimenting me
it was that an illusion about him
was exploded in front of my face in real
time
and it was like well wait a minute if
that if i was still hung up on maybe
he's anti-gay
or something or that a lot of people
still walk around thinking that trump's
racist that trump is truly racist the
guy who's right
here's a better example if you're a nazi
his daughter converted to judaism and
and i'm going to be very very serious
we're sitting here as two jews yeah
to divorce nazism from anti-semitism
is despicable and in any other context
people who are
uh students of history realize this is
very very wrong to regard these as
separate
uh concepts and separate phenomena they
go hand in hand
so to refer to someone as a nazi when
they welcome jews into their own family
converted jews
is really marginalizing the oppression
of many people who are relatives of guys
in the past and by the way these are the
same people who run around screaming
about cultural appropriation all the
time
and they're doing actually the most in
some ways you could argue the most
horrific type of cultural appropriation
uh but to answer your question you know
i mean it was a long slog for me but it
wasn't just
it wasn't just waking up to ideas and
reading thomas soul and actually sitting
down with him and
and meeting trump and sitting down with
him and then talking to guys like you
and realizing when i sat down suddenly
with prager
and with shapiro and and uh glenn beck
and all these people who
now yeah we kind of agreed to disagree
on some stuff that yes i've shifted in
their way
at some level obviously but it was like
they were nicer and more generous and
more lively
where the left everyone's afraid of
their shadow and people turn on each
other and it's
it's very unpleasant and most of my
friends on that side
actually i've realized aren't that great
and i found this other thing that's very
intellectually robust and interesting
and fun
um and real so it's a long freaking slog
but i would say it's uh
it's not just the political part it's
it's both those parts together
what were your concerns and were those
concerns
accurate because you were you know if
you become
an apostate in any ideology
you're a big target because if we lose
one
maybe this martin luther right right if
we lose this guy
we might be losing a lot of people right
now the signal gets out there well look
i mean look candace walked away also i
walked away plenty if not there's a
whole walk away movement
but i mean you've seen my twitter
responses like the endless barrage of
hate
from the people who purport to be
tolerant i mean you know and i've lost
friends i've had problems with
their family members who won't talk to
me is that true right now oh yeah
like close family members that won't
talk to me um
like you know the just the endless the
crazy
type of i'll give you one i had a
lifelong friend who i met at a bar in
new york city a couple years ago
we actually went to our we knew each
other from childhood went to college
together studied political science
together
played basketball together over the
years we always did this this thing that
we're doing we always did this about
everything
right i meet him at a bar it was obvious
that our politics were going in
different directions but this was before
i had said i was going to vote for trump
and we get in he's immediately just
attacking me we hadn't seen each other
in years he had just had a new kid
which i wanted to talk about i didn't
want to do politics he's go
just attacking me over and over and over
again and finally i said to him
i said do you think it's possible that i
believe what i believe
right as much as you believe what you
believe and without hesitation
he said no and i thought that level of
certitude
yeah is something that i want nothing to
do with but also the sense that you can
imagine someone saying this
and then as soon as the words come out
of their mouth you know like sometimes
like if i'm making fun of somebody i'll
go too far
and i hear it and they're like well i'm
sorry dave i didn't you know i didn't
mean it that way but right right
and you would catch yourself like what
what have i become that here's the other
i'm sorry
yeah well no i would just add one other
thing which is that that when you shed
all of those friends look i'd rather
be hated for who i am than loved for who
i'm not and it becomes obvious those
that doesn't it sounds like a cliche
when you say it
but then it really is something that's
real and when you realize that you're
standing up on your own two feet
and that you see the world in a certain
way and here i am and people are going
to hate me for it i love me for whatever
but it's better to be me
than to be someone else to be liked i
mean it's like the oldest story in the
book right
unconditional love means unconditional
it does not mean conditioned on who you
would prefer to have as president
which will have very little impact on
your daily life anyway let me just ask
you one more question if i may uh you
know being the guest on your show
can you compare to me your thought
process and your fears
about coming out as gay on september 10
2001
and coming out as being right of center
because you're also in very different
parts of your life
you know you're younger here you're you
know you don't have the financial
stability you don't have the the
platform necessarily here you're older
you know this was a million times harder
it's not even close
it's not even close politically i'm
talking about rather than coming out as
as gay i was 25 then yes i had internal
tumult
some some which by the way those the
ghosts of that live with me at 44. like
that's just
how life is but it was like an internal
thing and by the way when i started
coming out to people everybody reacted
great
there were one or two little family
things one or two you know people were
shocked i don't i don't act gay that's
what everyone kept telling me i don't
act gay
they don't really see me after 10 pm but
you know what i mean
not that um
but but it was in essence it was all
love and affirmation and great be who
you are and like fantastic this is
amazing and wonderful
this thing of doing this it's an endless
reckoning where where david now gets
messages on facebook that he's married
from friends of his
saying that they can no longer be
friends with him because he's married to
a nazi
or or a lot of people were messaging him
i mean a sizable amount of people former
friends of his
you're married to a terrorist after the
january 16th which obviously had nothing
to do with
and i wasn't there and blah blah blah
but that ongoing level of hate and and
to be here in la where i know that you
know i'm living in a city that's not
congruent with my beliefs sure and when
i go out you know most of the people
that say hi to me are nice but
you don't know what anyone else is
thinking and we also live in a time with
weird you know anything goes politically
and you're allowed to smash people over
the heads
with bottles and throw molotov cocktails
so like that ain't
fun so this has been way way harder i
would tell all the young people
listening to this who are scared of
coming out but it's better
no but i'll tell them if you
you're because the concern is and it's
not it's a realistic concern if you come
out as something
gay republican whatever it is i'm going
to lose a bunch of friends right
you want to lose that friends it's
better
to be hungry and looking for your next
meal or looking for
peers who like you as you it's going to
be tough in the medium term
it's going to be very tough then to be
trapped in a cage where you're fed like
a little talent every day
or trapped in a social group where you
if these people knew who you really were
they wouldn't like you or respect you
that is
you can live like that forever you are
never going to be happy and most
importantly
you are not going to be able to look at
yourself in the mirror
and having that capacity to be like i am
living true to my values
and my friends like me not despite them
but because of them to me that goes hand
in hand
with healthiness success and self-esteem
and when you're that kind of person
who stands up strong and is like this is
what i think this is who i am
that is very attractive in a business
sense
in a romantic sense and in a social
sense malice are you saying that we
should all stand up straight with our
shoulders back
somebody said that who said that wasn't
there some guy that was saying that for
a while people are weak
so they you know like i said earlier
they'd rather be safe than to be free
but for the most people the people that
i would like listen to me
what about the general idea that on this
side of things again you wrote the book
it was called the new right
yeah i'm on the back of the book called
you the willy wonka of politics
one of you one of your greatest
accolades i think i i love that
can i tell you one thing in all
seriousness uh harvey picard the late
comic book writer of american splendor
fame
he wrote a book about me called eagle
and hubris it came out in 2006 it goes
for 300
on ebay now i i've seen the pictures on
ebay yeah yeah
when i watch charlie and the chocolate
factory the johnny depp version which is
superior
i do cry a little bit and i'm not
kidding because
harvey gave me that golden ticket
harvey's the one who saw something
special in me
who saw someone unique and put his
reputation
on the line and said i'm going to write
a book about this freak
and that was such a major step in me
becoming independent
so if you're not if you are that special
person
and people don't like special they want
everything to be the same they want to
watch big bang theory they want to watch
you know uh chris cuomo when you're an
outlier
people aren't trained on how to handle
you some people will be drawn to you
a majority will be cut off by you but
when you meet your maker
i promise you are going to be able to
like you said hold your
head up high because you lived according
to
your values d so jordan's been uh since
i just mentioned jordan that what you
just said right there did you happen to
see the clip that went viral of jordan
in the last couple weeks
right um where he was on tucker
carlson's fox nation show
and he's talking about telling the truth
for truth's sake did you happen to see
this
so we're going to lay the clip in right
here you know you you
you make your decisions in life and i
decided when i was very
young i'm in my mid-20s that i was going
to say what i believed and see what
happened
i talked to you earlier in the talk
about adventure you know about
the adventure of truth and i don't
think i'm happy about what has happened
and i certainly have dragged my family
through their fair share of
well both hell and and also
incomprehensible opportunity
it's expanded our lives in both
directions to a tremendous degree
but it's certainly been an adventure
it's not been dull
and i don't believe that it i don't
believe that it was a mistake
whatever happens as a consequence of
telling the truth is the best thing that
can happen it doesn't really matter how
it looks to you at the moment
or maybe even across the years because
you have to it's it's a it's a
it's an article of faith in some sense
do you believe that reality is
better constituted as a consequence of
truth or falsity
if you believe that reality is best
constituted as a consequence of truth
then you have a responsibility to speak
the truth and you can't
assess the consequences and say well
that was a mistake because
part of the decision that reality is
best constituted
as a consequence of the truth is the
decision that no matter what happens
is the best if it's a consequence of
telling the truth
and so that's what i conclude it's like
this is what happened because i said
what i had to say
as clearly as i could say it and that's
as good as it could be
now whether or not that's good well it's
good compared to all possible
alternatives
all possible realistic alternatives
that's an article of faith as far as i'm
concerned you know our culture is
predicated on the idea
that truth in speech is of divine
significance it's the fundamental
presupposition of our culture
well if you believe that then you act it
out
and you take the consequences
you're going to take the consequences
one way or another you know
so you want the truth on your side
or do you want to hide behind falsehoods
okay so i think you understand why i
wanted to play that clip just as you
were saying that
it's very ein rand in his messaging
that's jordan peterson at his best a lot
of people who are fans of mine
are huge jordan fans you can i always
knew why
but seeing him work his magic first of
all just delight in a personal level
yeah that he's being bad that he's back
from his health issues that he's being
this cogent
but yeah rand iran had that point about
reality
is true it is the standard for what
truth
means and that's the definition of truth
that which corresponds to reality
ben shapiro you know obviously has a
very famous quote facts don't care about
your feelings
facts are what come first and if your
worldview
is based on facts as you understand them
we're all limited in our knowledge we're
going to make mistakes
or we're gonna have to kind of own them
and fix them
but if you are trying to act in a way
that corresponds to
reality that corresponds to what you
regard as true
even if you fail at least you will have
the self-esteem
of knowing you've fought the good fight
and truth is something that every one of
us has to learn
on our own even if you tell me dave that
this is a great painter for me to know
that it's true
i'll have to see it for myself and do
the mental work
you can't have that telepathy but so
much of corporate media
is the person in the screen telling you
this is what the science is
and me or whoever going on social media
and repeating it verbatim
that's not facts that's not truth that's
being a parrot
and that's why i've been saying we're in
a war on truth that's what this thing is
a war on truth
i wonder do you see where where rand and
maybe jordan are divergent is that at
the end he's saying that that is the
ultimate expression of faith
where i don't think she would go that
far and the reason i brought all of this
up was because i also wanted to link it
to that star that you've got on lapel
well
in terms of rand she was asked this on
donahue in 1979
i'm sure you're a big fan of and and her
point was
it's not when he the way he's using the
word face she goes he's like you have
faith that you
you know are accomplished or whatever
the question was she goes that's not
faith that's a
conviction so it's not faith in the
religious sense of
received knowledge from you know the
higher power or
you know i just have this uh emotional
experience with the divine and therefore
everything else follows
he means it in this okay i don't want
some words yeah the perception i got is
that he means
this is a conviction uh like an axiom
basically that's the leap to do that the
leap of faith to do that truth for truth
sakes
yeah yeah so i i i mean he's i
i i'm kind of it takes a lot for me to
sit here
and kind of not know what to say but
when he nails it like there's no one
better and
i think it's very very sick
that we have heard from the left
correctly
for a very long time that these young
men
are being raised without kind of models
for healthy behavior
and they result in negative consequences
rape culture is one of things where this
is like
you know no one's teaching these men not
to rape we need to teach them how to
rage
and jordan comes along and he tells
young people
your life can be better you can be a
better person tomorrow you may not be
perfect but you could still be the best
version of yourself
here are some concrete actionable items
to improve your life
and as a consequence of that as a
consequence of preaching
independence and self-improvement he's a
threat to the cathedral
and that's why he became public enemy
number one and you and i also have
seen and everyone listening to this has
seen the demented
glee in his uh chemical dependency yeah
and how people are happy that something
bad happened to him
whereas he has not i've never seen him
really wish harm on anyone
ever not once ever i can say that better
yeah i was on his show i'll tell you i
don't know when the episode's gonna drop
and he goes i'm not gonna do the voice
he goes the way you talk about
academics uh you know and just these
really nefarious terms
where does that leave me and me being me
i said jordan
you know you'd be the last one that
we're going to put up against the wall
and after the interview
and i have no doubt he had a huge laugh
he did of course i'm friends with
daughter mikhail i'm like i just said
your dad's gonna get shot
uh but it it you know after that clip
maybe we'll uh
uh find some space for him all right so
let's just link that
to that star that you've got on your
lapel and then i want to do two other
things with you relative to what's going
on in the world right now in israel and
everything else
i i think it is interesting uh i'm not
an authority in the middle east
but i think it is interesting how so
many times when you have a group
that's just burning everything down that
they are regarded as the heroes
simply because they're weak and violent
and we see this in nation after nation
and it's a very dangerous lesson uh to
lead uh
to teach people i think israel like any
country has the right to defend
themselves
and i also think if you are defending
yourself as a country if that's what
they're doing
this is a whole very very complicated
issue who's you know chicken and egg
i do not believe defense needs to be
proportionate
it can't be right i mean you'd actually
be an idiot right if you were doing
proper
if someone's breaking into your house
you don't just like break into them
right exactly okay let's do two more
things because
uh because i want to get some drinks
with the guy dressed like this
so we're going to everyone does yes here
i want to see you drink through the
masks
red wine through the mask it's going to
oh here we go oh this is how it ends
[Music]
um
you never disappoint malice you never
disappoint
um this cartoon that i just saw of you
this morning
you're doing a cartoon with tom woods
yeah very failed podcaster tom woods
uh it's a really wonderful no what do
you call it the non
the politically incorrect explanation of
communism i'm butchering it slightly
if they got a pig tv series so there's a
series of books by regenerating who i'm
sure
yeah gregory's doing great stuff they
they publish
and for decades they have been doing
good stuff so they had a series of books
called the politically correct guide to
a political
guide to feminism political great at the
constitution to the united states
so we adopted that uh and it's a series
of cartoons
me and tom are animated we discuss
issues like
the political right guide to communism
to the great depression to woodrow
wilson to american heroes
we're putting them out once a month and
it's
a great people the thing why i hate
government schools
and this is something that's not
controversial people learn
differently some people learn about
podcasts through conversation
some read learn by books some learn by
audio books some learn about
documentaries
none of these are right or wrong it's
just the human mind is nuance that
perceives
knowledge and information differently so
this is a fun way
for people to just sit down and learn
about these
epic issues that we're not going to
learn the truth about from the new york
times necessarily
and if you find it interesting you can
go on and explore from there so they're
bite-sized pieces that i'm really proud
of
what's the website again tv series dot
com politically correct guy tv series
they're just great they're light and fun
and and my goal tom again as i mentioned
earlier in the show he's a
dad catholic he's got five daughters my
goal is to get him in a dress in as many
episodes as possible
and i think i did a good job of that you
haven't got me in a dress yet
well not on camera that's right and he
wasn't really gonna get work
[Laughter]
um final thought here and i'm only i'm
actually not mentioning this for
promotional purposes i'm mentioning this
for purposes that are completely in line
with everything we've talked here
you're crushing it on locals you've
built something that is
awesome and great and you've got your i
always say there's no trolls on locals
and you always go well wait wait wait
wait wait wait uh but we've we've built
you your own community
where you're killing it basically i am
so grateful
to you and to my supporters it's
malice.locals.com as everyone knows
because my goal
wasn't like hey everybody i'm such a
badass my goal is
there are certain values that i hold
come to the community
you're going to find people who think
like you we'll have we'll discuss people
tell us pictures of their dog
they post pictures about their their
nephews they discuss politics
but you know it's a space where your
neighbor from high school like on
facebook
isn't going to wish death upon you and i
think there's
i was surprised and i think you were
very ahead of the curve on this
there's a huge ethos on the internet in
the same way that
when you got a restaurant you took the
waitress if you see a creator
that is making it happen you toss them a
few bucks
because they're the ones who are kind of
in the front lines taking the bullets
outsourcing of bravery
oh yeah i like that i'm going to pretend
i thought of that so
the fact that i have so many people who
are willing to toss me five bucks a
month for nothing in return i'm still
going to do the work
because they're like you are taking the
fight that i as a business owner
or a young professional aren't a
physician to do
that is very very humbling and
flattering and i
could not be more grateful and it also
means i don't have to be afraid
because if i had a situation with locals
i'd get on the phone with you
we would hash it out and we'd come to
some conclusion even we have to go our
separate ways
but i know i'm never gonna wake up and
have the community
vanished and have no explanation other
than press release
to be very clear michael you're not
getting on the phone with me because
that's not what i do but you'd get on
the phone with someone there
and guess what it's your committee you
do whatever the hell you want if you're
breaking the laws of the united states
you've got bigger problems than locals
you're taking my call reuben i'll take
your call anyway but not not about not
about this sort of stuff
you know uh malice i didn't know what i
was walking into you said to me that
you know i should sit here first before
seeing you my guys got to see you i
honestly thought you were going to be
dressed up
as bea arthur from the golden girls that
was my it was just my
gut feeling but you've you've surprised
me yet again
and thus you are the willy wonka of
politics
well thank you verruca i appreciate it
can you see my hand
i cannot
is it the finger if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of nonstop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell